on the economic effects of the floods
were joined by Alexander Shulman chief
economist at the association of German
chambers of commerce and industry the DI
HK welcome along first of all some of
the damage estimates that are going
around at the moment what figures are
you hearing we are looking on the
dramatic pictures from the flood areas
this is also true for the enterprise's
all kinds of enterprises of economic
activity is affected and we now know
that it's again a hundred years flood
and it's to estimate that also the
damages will be at the same level then
it was eleven years before so was a high
billion euro amount and this is what we
expect also for this flood so an
estimate around eleven billion euros
something like that this was the number
2002 and comparing to the damages we see
at the moment it's still unclear in the
the errors but what we can assess at the
moment it's yeah the level we can reach
also this time but if you compare that
11 billion euro amount or estimate to
what the government's pledging in
emergency aid of 100 million euros is
there a disconnect there yeah there's
still a huge difference between the the
amounts but this is okay because at the
moment what the people need in their
flood air is also the enterprises is a
rapid aid and these amounts these
million euro amounts are for these rapid
aid and then step by step if situation
becomes clearer they have to put more
into the aid and this will happen that
happened 2002 and this will happen also
this time and we're talking the whole
slider here businesses farmers factory
owners yeah the number you mentioned is
for the overall picture of
infrastructure also the damages for the
environment we have to it was necessary
to flood areas to to alleviate the
situation and
this will also to be included in the
damage amount now we saw in the report
the premiums for the insurance companies
or flood insurance premiums rather are
going to rise sharply how is this
flooding going to affect the insurance
companies and the reinsurance companies
themselves this phenomenon became worse
since the last hundred years flat 2002
since then premiums for the insurances
have become more expensive and now we
have to think about 2 to be the burden
on more shoulders than then normally
done also in industry associations say
that the floods may impede growth for
the German economy for a short time but
they haven't changed their growth
forecasts for the year as a whole why do
you think that is this is also our
scenario we expect still a good 0.5 GP
growth for the second quarter because
the flood is not an oval German
phenomenon and for the rest of the earth
for the year as a whole 30.3 percent gdp
growth slide plus but more due to the
euro debt crisis then to the flood and
is that also because you're factoring in
a bit of a boom this could happen that
happened 2002 especially for the
construction industry differently to
2002 now construction industry is at the
edge of capacities so first they have to
build up capacities and then they could
deal with the jobs in the flood areas
okay so lots of challenges ahead yeah
mr. Sherman thank you very much for your
time